hey guys this is andrew from
chainsenses.com so i've been working as
a professional trader for the past six
years in hong kong
and right now i'm doing youtube videos
because guys i want to pass the
knowledge i want to show you how
actually procedures are working how i
work
different tools and techniques that i
use because i know that
you know if you're here it's because you
want to have some answers you want to
know
is it really possible to make money on
the market the answer is yes
but is it easy to find what to use and
where you can find all the information
you need
no and you should not listen to anyone
you know most of people
just repeat what they say so they're not
saying you know stupid things you know
what i say is right you know when i look
at the other youtubers i'm like [ __ ] man
yeah this is correct
but they don't give the whole
information so they don't explain
exactly how to use those tools precisely
and efficiently because they don't know
because they don't do it all right
i'm doing it this is my job so if you
want to know about all this stuff guys
you are in the right place
so today i want to make an update on
fubu let's get into it
[Music]
guys i know that a lot of people are
along the staff
you know even in my family it's been
long time people are talking to me about
this stuff
uh zack morris you know the twitter
store is long as well
but the real person that is long in the
stuff is cathy wood guys all those
people
you know from reddit from twitter from
wall street bets
they get the information there are some
smart people there that hang out on this
forum and give the
stock list that they actually take from
cathy wood arc investment management
you know the edge hedge fund that got
the biggest result
uh this year and is probably gonna keep
overperforming
all these competitors so she knows how
to pick up stocks i'm pretty sure she's
using technical analysis you know
but a hedge fund is of course you know
not only technical analysis they're also
doing fundamental analysis and they
analyze
a lot of stuff and they are quite good
at this so fubu tv
is one of their targets she's along the
staff and
i'm here to just give you some updates
and some targets so
my view is definitely i'm long i'm
bullish
here where you can find so what is
happening the price action is just
drifting lower
guys this is expected i mean you know a
stock like this
it's not zero volatility all right it's
just going higher but
doing some ups and downs so right now
we're doing it down we broke the two
20 and 50 period moving average and the
next support level guys is at 23.
so i wouldn't buy it here i would wait
for 23 and then i would
and especially you're gonna have you
know probably
the 200 period moving average that is
gonna come
like this all right if i have something
like this and the price session looking
like this then here it would be a very
nice level to buy and then probably
you're gonna have something like this
and then
it maybe in one month or something like
this so i i don't know maybe it's gonna
get bullish right away i'm just saying
if you're alone keep it if you're not
long don't buy it here guys this is not
a
good level to buy the stuff you have a
lot of opportunities guys go to clbs for
example it's
it's a very nice level to buy tesla at
500 is very nice we're not there yet but
we're going there
you have a lot of opportunities so don't
waste your money by just buying
things randomly pick up the ones where
you have the best reactions
let's go check the short interest let's
see if hedge funds are shorting it
so i'm gonna check two stuff so guys i
go on market bit you can go on market
watch
uh the data is updated every two weeks
so i encourage you to go check it by
yourself you know
if you want to be a trader be a real
trader and check your data
short interest is low guys 16 so
i don't expect any short squeeze you
know but
i expect still a move up but i don't
know
how it's going to happen but probably
not very violently and institutional
ownership what are doing
hedge funds and asset managers no data
right i just have here something very
bullish but this is obviously not true
and once again i want to remind you guys
that i'm very bullish on everything on
everything that is hard because i think
we are entering a bubble and if you want
to know why go check it out on my videos
on snp and nasdaq bubble that i did
a few days or last week and i explained
exactly guys why
i have this view and why i think that
the markets are just gonna go insanely
higher so that's it for me guys and
don't forget to click the sub like and
bell button so you're gonna be the first
to know when i upload anything new
and stay close to show i'll see you guys